mistakes make tons of mistakes made
mistakes mr. mistakes making mistakes
and make mistakes make mistake who made
mistakes make mistakes
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you have inside
here come out and explode into the world
to make it a better place instead I'll
help you on your journey today we're
gonna learn how to make mistakes and as
always guys as you watch it if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can learn and be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well enjoy
[Music]
what one thing we've failed to do in the
educational system is alert people that
if you're doing what no one has done
before stuff goes wrong and in fact if
nothing ever goes wrong in what you're
doing if you make no mistakes in your
job in your in whatever task you've
brought upon yourself then you are not
on the frontier simple mm-hmm it's true
in science and I heard it applied to car
racing there's a quote that I'm told
spoken by Mario Andretti he said if you
are in complete control of your car
you're not in the race Wow there's
something that is just not completely in
control I like that and only then get
and that's the same thing I'm describing
for when you are on the frontier so many
things go wrong when you're starting a
company and often I think people ask you
know what mistakes should you avoid
making and you know my answer that
question is don't even bother trying to
avoid mistakes because you're gonna make
tons of mistakes right and the the
important thing is actually learning
quickly from whatever mistakes you make
and not giving up right and I mean there
are things every single year of
Facebook's existence that could have
killed us or made it so that it just
seemed like moving forward and making a
lot of progress just seemed intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and nothing is impossible you just
have to kind of keep running through the
walls you don't have to hold yourself
hostage to who you used to be or
anything you ever used to do because who
has lived and hasn't made mistakes when
I think about my 20s and what a foolish
girl I was and how I would give over my
power to men who really didn't mean me
well but now I hold no grudges against
them either because I realized I'm the
one who gave over the power because I
didn't know any better and now that I
know better I know I don't have to do
that again it's one of the most powerful
lessons any of us can ever know
you succeed you must first learn to fail
you know a lot of people that fail they
get down on themselves but the vessel
sports stars learn from their mistakes
now I should have did this okay we'll do
that make sure and just keep learning
until you get to the point to where
you're the champion and then everybody
needs to compete you took me eight years
before I got my first championship and
after that we won three in a row
lost two and I got another one moved so
it's not easy but you know it's not a
it's not a specific time period of how
long it takes you deserve to learn from
your mistakes
you make mistakes and then so many
people come up to me and say Gary it's
so hard I look at their Instagram and
they're not posting any of their content
with hashtags which is a by accident way
to pick up exposure in a world where
they have no money when you have no
money when I took over my dad's business
it did three million dollars a year ten
percent gross profit $300,000 before
expenses my first year marketing budget
was fourteen thousand dollars when you
have no money
and I built that business from a three
to a sixty million dollar business in
five years I had to make every penny
perfect so I was right about email
marketing in ninety six and I was right
and because of that I had 91% open rates
when Google AdWords came out the day it
came out I paid five cents a click for
words before anybody bid me up and I was
super right and that worked if it does
that lock versus preparation and do you
ever get anything wrong what do you do I
can make them as high I get everything
wrong it's just that I can't recall it
because once it's wrong I'm moving on to
the next thing
like dwell dwelling on what you up on is
the quickest way for the next thing not
to work right yeah so like so I think I
do everything I mean you know this this
is a fun thing to say some people in the
back know this I was a breakout YouTube
star in the first year 2006 I decided
that the right strategy was to leave
YouTube completely and go to viddler
because viddler offered me equity in
their company and I've left an enormous
amount of attention I deviated from my
intention thesis to do short-term
economics and equity in a company and I
lost I lost Wendy Brock finally came in
my life two years ago we started
try to build up my YouTube for the first
time I was sitting on 40,000 user
followers in a world where I could have
had millions if I just stayed the course
so I make mistakes all the time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year I just don't give a
[ __ ] about my mistakes everybody else
cares about your mistakes if you're
worried about your own mistakes you've
already lost making it through that
first performance I guess was in many
ways a relief but we also quickly
realized there was a lot of work to be
done and a lot of improvements that had
to be made with the full-scale festival
tour throughout Europe just eight weeks
away well we really had to get our grind
on also super-nervous
I was like oh my god I can't believe I'm
doing this
[Music]
basically had all the festivals that we
wanted that summer Tomorrowland
Creamfields Lollapalooza we had a solid
plan for the whole summer
[Music]
then came the phone call hi guys we got
a call from the US does I want to do
support on a Rihanna tour I was like
okay can't say no to this
do I really dare to say yes I think
every rookie makes mistakes and
certainly so did Alan as well the big
difference though is that most people
are fortunate enough to do that within
you know there are pre-production
rehearsals or whatever Alan did it on
his first show on the first leg of the
Rihanna tour in front of 70,000 people I
was lucky and actually hit the cue
button on one of the songs and I messed
up that wasn't supposed to happen
Alan in that part of his career that it
was shouldn't be doing mistakes I hate
myself for every mistake that I make but
I also know that making mistakes and
learning from them is an important part
of the process if I didn't make any
mistakes then I probably wouldn't have
been where I am today every man in this
room you met you blew your twenties you
spend all your 30s trying to make up for
the old 20s yeah that's not after truth
dawg every dude in this room blew they
twenties and it thirty trying to fix
what they should've did in a 20s yeah
and so so for a song you turn 40 you're
trying to recover from the mistakes you
made when you 30 now have fought it many
times you start really at 30 you need to
start buckling it on down and just
realize man everybody make mistakes and
if the mistakes you going through are
gonna help you become the person you
need to be later on Steve Harvey all the
mistakes don't they cool to make you I
needed to mess up every marriage I
needed to get arrested like I did I
needed to get shot I needed all this dog
I need to be homeless yeah
because all the people that beat up man
you get shot it it don't hurt it just
burn that's a completely I'm telling you
what you want
I needed all them things to happen to
turn me into Who I am today so when
you're young and you make mistakes don't
let them eat you up because everybody
that didn't made it that made yeah you
got to fail in order to win Hey look man
to understand how to hit the game with a
shot you got to miss the game when it
shot Steve Harvey listen what I think is
important is not dwelling on mistakes
and not trying to play so safe that you
don't make any mistakes I think that's
the biggest thing that a lot of
entrepreneurs do wrong and get wrong
they're so worried about fear and so
worried about making the wrong step and
making every little tiny mistake that
they're spending so much time focusing
on the negative and avoiding the
negative instead of spending your energy
you're tying your resources on the
positive and how you can do something
amazing you have to understand that
making mistakes is part of the process
you will make mistakes it's normal its
natural its inevitable and through the
mistakes you'll learn and keep going and
make it better the next time and better
the next time
and so it's adopting a mentality that
make mistakes it's okay it's gonna
happen I've had lots of bad luck in my
life but I think having bad luck is
equally as important because when you
have bad luck in life you have to
reflect you have to take the knowledge
from that experience
we've all been treated badly we've all
made mistakes
we've all had bad luck so what we have
to do is reflect take the knowledge from
that experience and then I'll allow it
to enrich our life it's as simple as
that
let's be honest when people say Germany
regrets Marco I say no because I did not
be for all those mistakes I made gonna
be here I won't I wouldn't have the
knowledge that I have today I don't have
the experience that I have to
because mistakes are fine as long as you
take the knowledge from the mistakes I
continually learn from my mistakes and
other people's mistakes see
entrepreneurs think that hey to create
that billion-dollar company 100 million
dollar company or even million dollar
company have to be really smart and sure
brains is part of it luck is a huge
component but what I've learned over the
years is everyone no matter how smart
you are you're gonna fail many times and
you're gonna make mistakes just look at
Mark Zuckerberg Facebook worked out his
version of snapchat that was a copycat
did not work out right so there's other
areas in which Facebook failed but
Facebook overall as a company has done
great just because you're smart doesn't
mean you're always gonna succeed with
everything you try or touch but every
time you do something you will learn new
things you'll make mistakes and if you
learn from these mistakes and avoid
making them over and over again you'll
actually increase your odds of
succeeding as time goes on and the best
way to do this is not just to learn from
your mistakes but it's also to learn
from the mistakes of others Rockefeller
Carnegie all these people who are
entrepreneurs years ago in the 1800's
1900s they themselves use business
principles and concepts that are still
applicable in today's world sure we have
the internet but the same strategies and
concepts that they use are still
applicable right so learn from their
mistakes learn will work for them what
didn't work for them why and bring that
into what you're doing today thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what did you
think of this video what was the message
that stuck most true to you what are you
going to immediately apply somehow to
your life or to your business please
leave it down in the comments below
I look forward to hearing what you have
to say I also want to give a quick shout
out to Celia Lopez Celia thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and taking that picture
and post it to Twitter I really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed the read so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
one of all you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]